We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P. here's
a caller who says, listen, he likes what I
say.
He just doesn't like my face.
Take a listen to this.
How's it going?
David Kahler here from upstate New York.
Just wanted to say that like I think I would
agree with you on most things politically
think we're on the same page.
Just on criticism for your show.
Like yes, ACE man, it's just not working out.
I don't, I don't know if a mask would work
or maybe some plastic surgery asserts, but
you use this pretty ugly.
My guy.
Yeah, he's probably work on, but you know
you're killing it with the political thing.
Thank you.
You know you get that string that was like
probably watch you some more, but I have a
good one.
Listen, this is someone who says, if I had
a different face, they would likely watch
more now.
Why they can't just listen.
I don't know, but I love the, the, the new
term plastic surgery.
I think it's a combination of surgery and
sorcery, and I would love it if someone set
that up as a definition on urban dictionary.
Quoting the David Pakman show, plastic surgery,
the recommendation there.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Join patman.com to get instant access.
I'll speak to you on the bonus show, the David
Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].